[Music]
Miami April 11th 1986 one of the
bloodiest days in FBI history special
agents including 25-year veteran
Benjamin Grogan and his young partner
Jerry dove corner a car driven by two
violent bank robbers an intense gun
battle ensues over a hundred rounds are
fired when the shooting stops the two
gunmen are dead but so are special
agents Grogan and Dove five other
special agents are wounded in the fierce
firefight neither one of the slain
special agents was wearing a bulletproof
vest that day soon after new FBI
regulations made vests mandatory rookie
special agent Stephanie shark has to
adjust to the dangers of the job she's
only been with the FBI for three months
it's not a traditional job that every
little girl grows up thinking you know
they want to carry a gun and go kick
down doors and put handcuffs on people
who are usually bigger than you most of
the women that I know in this field have
a little bit of spunk to them and they
have a fire inside them that drives them
after more than two decades as a special
agent bill got four he's still driven to
bring the bad guys to justice he started
out as a cop after about five years I
had made detective and I just decided
that I wanted to work larger
investigations I'd left to come with the
FBI I wanted to play on a higher level
so to speak Special Agent Steve Beano
came to the bureau three years ago after
serving as an engineer in the armies of
the things that drew me to the FBI one
is the sense of being able to make a
real difference the other thing was the
sense of team the FBI as a team is
something that really attracted me shark
Godfrey and Vino are members of one of
America's most elite federal law
enforcement agencies 12,000 special
agents are spread across the nation at
56 field offices covering a population
of 1.7 million people Norfolk's special
agents like their counterparts across
America bring some of humanity's
nastiest individuals to justice
nobody is better at capturing dangerous
criminals than the FBI in 1950 the
bureau invented the ten most wanted to
enlist the public's help in tracking
fugitives it worked
94% of the individuals who've appeared
on the list have been apprehended among
the ten most wanted were ramzi yousef
ringleader of the 1993 World Trade
Center bombing Eric Rudolph the Atlantic
Olympics bomber the man who murdered
Martin Luther King jr. James Earl Ray
and serial killer Ted Bundy